The joe rogan experience.
Just the anecdotal research that some of these people have,
uh,
had these incredibly life changing experiences.
But I think one of the things that you're saying is I think very important is
that this isn't for everybody and that if you have problems with normal
consciousness,
this is likely not for you.
If you're one of those people that has schizophrenia and your family perhaps.
Yeah.
And in fact those people are screened out of this research very carefully.
It's,
it's a real issue with people with a psilocybin and Ma and many psychedelics,
right?
Yeah.
What happens with schizophrenia is if you are at risk for it,
um,
either for,
uh,
because of inheritance,
um,
a psychedelic trip can set you off,
can be the trigger for a life of it and other things can to a divorce your
parents getting divorced sets people off,
go to graduate school,
sets people off.
If you're someone who's probably going to get schizophrenia,
any kind of mental trauma,
if it happens that,
that window,
which is in your early twenties,
in your late twenties,
I think.
Um,
and that's,
that's why we did see some cases because that's the age people were using
psychedelics in the 60s of having their first psychotic break.
So,
yeah.
So if you're at risk for that or,
or bipolar as well,
by the way.
That's right.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Marijuana can do it.
Also,
I think the,
the,
the numbers though mirror the numbers,
uh,
in standard populations when it terms of like,
I think it's one out of 10,
like one out of 10 people have some form of schizophrenia and that's mirrored in
marijuana use.
I didn't know that.
That's really,
I think it's the same.
I think the problem is,
you know,
it can exacerbate it or it can trigger it or,
depending upon,
I mean,
everyone's biology's different and everyone's,
uh,
the,
the way they absorb these,
these chemicals is different.
Yeah.
And you know,
if you are at risk,
something's going to do it eventually.
Um,
so,
you know,
we,
we don't have any evidence of someone thrown into a situation of schizophrenia
or other serious mental illness as a result of a,
strictly because of a psychedelic experience.
It may have been the trigger,
but there might have been,
it was going to happen anyway.
We just don't know.
But in general,
if you've got serious,
if you have personality disorder,
if you have bipolar,
if you are at risk for schizophrenia,
they will not accept you into these trials and you should stay away from these
drugs.
Yeah.
Um,
that,
that is a real problem with it being prohibited.
The prohibition has really set back research and understanding decades.
I mean,
we should have been studying this stuff since the 60 is 30 years of hiatus in
the research.
I don't know if another time where you had a promising line of scientific
inquiry all through the fifties and early sixties,
that's just choked off.
And for 30 years,
nothing happened.
I mean,
think of what we would know if we had 30 more years of research with his drugs.
It's crazy.
So now we're picking up the,
and all that research is being resumed,
but your,
but your point about prohibition is really important.
When you have prohibition,
you can't regulate something.
It's a free for all.
Um,
whereas if you did legalize silicide,
let's take as an example,
you could set rules.
You could say that it can only be administered by licensed guides or in a
medical context,
or that no one under a certain age can have it.
I mean,
it gives you a chance to regulate,
and that's why it's Saner to,
to legalize,
not in a free for all kind of way,
but in a,
in a very considered way than to have the system we have now where people are
going to take the drug,
whether they should or not without any kind of clearance.
Uh,
and by the way,
who knows what you're getting.
You,
you know,
you can also regulate the,
the strength and the,
um,
and in the case of Lsd,
you know,
in the 60s,
there was this period where there was a lot of pure LSD round,
and then the mob got an interest in it and they started cutting it with speed
and all sorts of things,
and people got into a lot of trouble.
Okay.